this might be a nice uh
segue into what barstool sports is doing
to wrestle yeah exactly that's exactly
what i was looking at dave portnoy
raised 16.9
16. a million dollars for 59 small
business owners and counting
and he launched the fundraising effort
with the non-profit
30-day fund for small businesses
impacted by cova 19 called the barstool
fund
last week and contributed 500 000 of his
own money
towards the effort do you have the video
ready kai or no if we have the video
just to kind of show uh what was said
it's it's uh it's great to see a guy
like that just going out there
supporting small businesses go ahead
just play 30 seconds of the united
states new york city
just shut down indoor dining it's like
how do you expect these people to
survive
how a restaurant is going to survive
they're already on their last legs and
you're pulling the plug look at the
sweaters
the camera and the government or at
least they're not doing anything acting
like they care
no plan no relief no bailout
it's like what's going to happen so i
was renting raven about it marcus limon
has challenged me he's like why don't
you put your money where your mouth is
well i've spent the last couple days
doing exactly that
so we're going to donate half a million
dollars and we've come up with a plan is
it the best plan no
the best plan is the government getting
off their ass and issuing
relief billions of dollars to these
small business owners or losing their
livelihoods
and have no recourse and no way to save
it through no fault of their own
billions of dollars
that's the solution that's the only
solution really but
barring that we're going to do what we
can it's the bar stool fund
it is modeled around frankie bareilly
you know frankie
all right frankie where are we at
frankie my cameraman for the peace
reviews
well his dad owns borellis in long
island the perfect example
of the type of business we're trying to
save throughout this pandemic
i'm like hey frankie how's your dad
doing how's borelli's doing every month
it gets a little bleaker
um so what this is 30 years old single
restaurant
and they have no indoor dining so not
only
that but mr braley credit to him who
would never want to take a handout in
his life
also is still paying his employees he's
never shut off his payroll
so it's like i'm going down to the ship
i can't so by the way he kept calling
people facetiming him surprising him oh
my gosh
awesome man awesome we need more people
like this man for a fantastic job he did
what do you think about what he did here
with raising 16.9 million dollars with
59 different business owners
i think for the most part people want to
help i think people are looking for a
way to help out and i think good good
job portnoy i think that's amazing
you know he's ticked off at cnn because
cnn will not cover this story
that kai if you pull up something from
today he's he's going on a rampage about
the fact that
mainstream media is is ignoring
basically what he's doing
but i think it's phenomenal and hell he
i think they could do a telethon and
raise hundreds of millions because i do
think people
i want to help the people i want to do
something that i can to support small
businesses where i live i don't want
them to go
under it is unfair what's happening to
them so
good good job have you seen
i mean all on his instagram it's for his
last
20 or so posts and i checked it uh i
don't know a handful of days ago so i'm
surprised
this guy does he just randomly or
facetime the owner
of a of a bar of a restaurant wherever
all over the world
not sorry all over the country
california indiana ohio new york texas
and he says hey and they
like we did this obviously with
valuetainment it reminded me of that
and someone picks up oh damn what's up
bbd oh
damn you know it's awesome when you see
that genuine reaction
question is he randomly picking them or
are they asking for help are they
reaching
they give a video that says hey dave
okay like hey barstool i hope you see
this
okay here's what's going on and then
they'll play that clip
and then dave responding like oh damn
what's up like
i think you know the reason we're
calling like it's it's awesome yeah
something that we can
you know kudos man for sure more more
power to him do you know who he was the
last uh week or so
partying itself was it really yeah yeah
i ran you know
you ran into him yeah same place yeah
this place called swan
in south beach yeah he was there table
him five girls
that's it him five yes there it is
yeah straight up the guy have you ever
seen but there were other people there
obviously
tyga the rapper was there and uh shout
out to the uh
the um groot hospitality group that
throw the party at swan but yeah
um we have to live vicariously through
adam yeah we do
what were you doing drinking in a bar i
was i was i was drinking at a bar and i
was uh that's the american way
i had my mask on i would use a straw i
would sip and no
seriously no i mean i can actually see
you going with a mess two bars did you
really have a mask on at the bar
you have to show up with a mask and then
when you go in here like just at any
restaurant
then if it's got it look yeah most
people that were parting out there
no masks no no nothing whatever a lot of
it was outdoors
that's the difference in in miami you go
to in south florida
70 and gorgeous right now in january
right
knock on wood everybody but if you're in
new york
like there's no outdoor dining there's
no nothing so there's people flying down
to to get the good life in but uh and
he's one of them
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you